son tiempos de elecciones y hay una
segunda vuelta entre el candidato am y
el candidato b
nosotros somos encuestadores y estamos
interesados en saber qué tan probable es
que el candidato
gane las elecciones idealmente
consultaríamos a toda la población de
posibles votantes pensemos que son
100.000 y nos gustaría preguntarles a
cada uno de ellos por quién votaría de
este censo podríamos conseguir la
proporción poblacional que es la
proporción de votantes que apoya al
candidato a sin embargo no sería
realista preguntarles a cada uno de los
100.000 votantes en su lugar hacemos lo
que tendemos a hacer en estadística
muestrear esta población y calcular el
estadístico a partir de esa muestra para
estimar este parámetro supongamos que
tomamos una muestra aquí cuyo tamaño es
igual a 100 y calculamos la proporción
muestral que apoya al candidato a así
que digamos que de los 100 encuestados
54 apoyan al candidato a por lo tanto la
proporción muestral es de 0.54 hay que
tomar en cuenta que no siempre vamos a
obtener en 0.54 podemos pensar que si
tenemos una muestra distinta de 100
personas tal vez obtengamos una
proporción muestral diferente por
ejemplo de 0.58
ya sabemos de vídeos anteriores que las
distribuciones muestrales son la
herramienta estadística que nos permite
hacer inferencias sobre una población a
partir de una muestra en este caso vamos
a trabajar con la distribución muestral
de proporciones y esta distribución será
específica para el tamaño de nuestra
muestra para n igual a 100 entonces
podemos describir las posibles
proporciones muestrales que obtuvimos y
sus probabilidades con esta distribución
muestral
dado que el tamaño de la muestra es
mucho menor que la población es mucho
menor que el 10% podemos suponer que
cada persona encuestada es un evento
independiente además si suponemos que la
proporción real no es muy cercana a 0 o
no es muy cercana a 1 entonces podemos
suponer que esta distribución muestral
es aproximadamente una distribución
normal así que tenemos esta curva con
forma de campana
tenemos esta normal ya sabemos mucho
sobre la distribución muestral de
proporciones por ejemplo ya sabemos que
la media de esta distribución muestral
es igual al valor real de la proporción
poblacional también sabemos cuál será la
desviación estándar de esta distribución
si desconoces esto te sugiero que veas
los vídeos sobre este tema en khan
academy tal vez esta sea una desviación
estándar dos desviaciones estándar tres
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media y una desviación estándar dos
desviaciones estándar tres de ellas por
debajo de la media entonces esta
distancia esta desviación estándar de
aquí que denotamos como la desviación
estándar de la distribución muestral de
proporciones será bueno ya conocemos la
fórmula será la raíz cuadrada
que multiplica a 1 p donde p recordemos
es la proporción poblacional y esto
entre el tamaño de la muestra en este
caso sabemos que n es igual a 100 en
este primer caso vamos a enfocarnos en
este cuando trabajamos con un tamaño de
muestra de n igual a 100 y tenemos una
proporción muestral de 0.54 y podríamos
obtener todo tipo de resultados por aquí
tal vez 0.54 está por aquí tal vez 0.54
está por aquí y la razón del por qué
tenemos esta incertidumbre es que no
sabemos cuál es el parámetro poblacional
real es decir cuál es la proporción
poblacional real pero vamos a hacernos
una pregunta sencilla cuál es la
probabilidad
de que la proporción muestral que es
0.54 esté dentro de dos desviaciones
estándar de p
pausa el vídeo y piénsalo es decir si
tomamos una muestra y calculamos su
proporción muestral cuál es la
probabilidad de que se encuentre dentro
de dos desviaciones estándar de la media
bueno esencialmente será esta área de
aquí y sabemos que para una distribución
normal aproximadamente el 95% del área
está dentro de dos desviaciones estándar
así que la respuesta es aproximadamente
el 95 por ciento es decir 95% de las
veces que tomemos un tamaño de muestra
de 100 y calculemos la proporción
muestral ésta se ubicarán dentro de dos
desviaciones estándar
y a partir de este enunciado podemos
construir otro que empiece a sentirse un
poco más podemos decir inferencial
podemos escribir que existe un 95 por
ciento de probabilidad de que la
proporción poblacional p
esté dentro de dos desviaciones estándar
con respecto a p sombrero que es igual a
0.54 pausa el vídeo y observa que estos
dos enunciados son equivalentes si
existe un 95 por ciento de probabilidad
de que la proporción muestral esté entre
dos desviaciones de estándar de la
proporción real esto es equivalente a
decir que existe un 95 por ciento de
probabilidad de que la proporción real
esté entre dos desviaciones estándar de
la proporción muestral
este segundo enunciado es muy muy
interesante ya que si somos capaces de
encontrar el valor de la desviación
estándar entonces podremos construir lo
que llamamos un intervalo de confianza
posiblemente ya te diste cuenta de que
hay un problema para poder calcular la
desviación estándar de esta distribución
necesitamos conocer el parámetro
poblacional así que pausar vídeo y
piensa qué podemos hacer si no conocemos
el valor de p si no conocemos la
proporción poblacional tenemos algo que
podamos usar como un estimado de la
proporción poblacional
claro ya calculamos p sombrero
calculamos la proporción de la muestra
entonces podemos definir un nuevo
estadístico llamado error estándar el
error estándar de las proporciones
muestrales y podemos definirlo como la
raíz cuadrada y ya que no conocemos la
proporción poblacional usaremos la
proporción muestral de peso hombre por
uno menos p sombrero todo esto entre n y
en este caso en es igual a 100 ya
sabemos esto aunque no vamos a probarlo
en este vídeo en realidad resulta que
este es un estimador in sesgado para la
desviación estándar entonces esto será
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 0.54 por 1 -
0.54 que es 0.46 todo esto entre 100
entonces tenemos la raíz cuadrada de
abrimos paréntesis 0.54 x 0.46 entre 100
cerramos paréntesis intro
y si redondeamos el milésimo más cercano
tendremos aproximadamente cinco
centésimos y 0.05 esto es
aproximadamente 0.05 entonces otra forma
de decir todas estas cosas aunque no
conocemos el valor de esta desviación es
que ahora tenemos una estimación podemos
establecer entonces que existe un 95% de
confianza ya esto se le conoce como
nuestro nivel de confianza de que la
proporción real se ubique entre dos
errores estándar por debajo de la
proporción muestral esto es 0.54 menos 2
por 0.05 entre 100
30 puntos 54 menos 0.1 que es 0.44 /
0.44 y dos errores estándar por arriba
de la proporción muestral esto es 0.54 +
2 por 0.05 entre 100
esto es 0.54 más 0.1 que es 0.64
0.64 de los votantes apoyan al candidato
y este intervalo que tenemos aquí de
0.44 a 0 64 será nuestro intervalo de
confianza este cambiará no sólo en el
punto inicial y el punto final sino
también en el ancho del intervalo
dependiendo de qué proporción muestral
calculemos para este tamaño de 100
votantes una idea relacionada con el
intervalo de confianza es el concepto de
margen de error para esta muestra en
particular ya que requerimos un
intervalo de confianza del 95% nuestro
margen de error será dos errores
estándar nuestro margen de error aquí
será bueno de dos errores estándar es
decir 0.1 entonces tenemos un margen de
error por arriba de la proporción
muestral el límite superior que tenemos
aquí y también tenemos un margen de
error por debajo de la proporción
muestral es decir el límite inferior que
tenemos acá
y así obtenemos nuestro intervalo de
confianza como mencionamos este margen
de error tampoco será fijo debido a que
se calcula con el error estándar el cual
depende de la proporción muestral otra
interpretación de esto es que el método
que usamos para obtener este intervalo
de aquí el método que utilizamos para
obtener este intervalo de confianza
cuando lo usamos una y otra vez
producirá varios intervalos y estos no
serán siempre los mismos ya que
dependerán de nuestra proporción
muestral y podemos considerar que el 95%
de los intervalos que se obtengan
contendrán la proporción poblacional
real en vídeos futuros desarrollaremos
esto de manera intuitiva
veremos cómo cambian los intervalos y el
margen de error y también veremos que
cuando hacemos estos cálculos una y otra
vez el 95% de los intervalos contenta
la proporción real ahora otra pregunta
interesante es qué pasaría si queremos
reducir el ancho de los intervalos como
haremos eso bueno si queremos reducir
nuestro margen de error la mejor forma
de hacerlo es aumentar el denominador lo
que significa aumentar el tamaño de la
muestra así que frecuentemente se
observa que cuando la gente habla de una
mayor cobertura electoral esto quiere
decir que se necesita muestrear a más
personas para así obtener un margen de
error menor por ahora me despido nos
vemos en los siguientes vídeos